on the flu vaccines in massachusetts
they're mandating that children get flu
vaccines in order to go back to school
there's a controversy about that a lot
of parents like whoa we you know
we don't we don't want our kids get the
flu vaccines are you worried that on the
push for vaccines these fast vaccines
for covet
you might be splitting a coalition of
americans
frankly in both parties who aren't
comfortable
well once you get to a certain number
you know we use the word heard
right once you get to a certain number
it's going to go away so you know it
doesn't have to be
but yeah i mean a lot of people are not
going to want to do it a lot of people
don't want to
do the flu should it be mandatory you
know i never had the flu but i never had
a shot i never had the vaccine
i come here the first thing sir you have
to have a flu shot
i said why because you have to have it i
say what's the percentage and i wasn't
thrilled with the percentage you know
it's like fifty percent
fifty-five well dr fauci said it might
not give quote great protection
because it's a coronavirus well i said
look if i've never had it wouldn't it be
good
and then i thought i should have it
because i'll set an example so i had it
so i've had it now
three times but and i still haven't had
the flu
so maybe i'll give credit to the flu
vaccine i don't know if
i can say this you'll you'll uh
i think we're gonna have a vaccine very
soon a lot of tremendous work has been
done
you're gonna have a vaccine just like we
have therapeutics which to me are even
more important you go into the hospital
yet
make people better that's to me the most
but
and we just did the convalescent plasma
i think and you have other things too
so i think we're gonna have a lot of
therapeutics and we're gonna have a
vaccine very soon
as to whether or not people take it 35
say they're not going to take the
covenant vaccine they don't want it they
shouldn't be manchester but if you
add 35 to the people that have had it
and to all of the other things you know
people that have had it where in theory
you can't get it although they found
one person and they're making a big deal
one person got it twice
but if you end it all up it it gives you
very good protection
um biden says he would shut down the
economy again
if the scientists said that was the
right thing to do in the fight against
covington
would you well i think it's a very
dangerous statement for him to make look
we knew
we did the right thing we shut it down
and now we built it up and we're setting
records on job numbers we're setting
records on retail numbers
so this guy comes and i heard it the
other day if they said so that means
that if
some doctor said we have to shut it down
we're going to shut it down
we're setting records by the way the
stock market is at an
all-time record right now you look at
what's going on in the stock market look
at what's going on
this we're gonna have a phenomenal year
next year we're gonna have a great third
quarter interestingly
the numbers for the third quarter will
come out before the election
are you worried if something happens on
the market in a correction
well i'll tell you i can tell you what
is happening nancy pelosi doesn't want
to give any stimulus we should have it
wasn't the people's fault
that china gave us this virus china gave
us the virus
whether it was through incompetence or a
person we called you a domestic
enemy an enemy of the state your
supporters how do you work with her
on another stimulus well i always tell
will that happen i always tell her to go
back to
san francisco take care of your homeless
problem take care of your problem in
california because there's nothing like
what i'm witnessing out there
right outside right where she lives
right in her district is so bad needles
all over
will you get a stimulus or not well we
should have we'd like to get it for the
people
because it wasn't their fault but she
doesn't want to give it because that
will make the economy a little bit
better and that would be a terrible
thing
if you had to do it all again i know
that's kind of a hard question but
do it all again would you put fouchy
front and center
every day in charge of the coronavirus
task force i get along with him very
well i disagree with a lot of what he
said he said keep it
open for china that was a big mistake
and he admits it
uh i just i get along with him but every
once in a while he'll come up with one
that i say
where did that come from i inherited him
he was here he was a part of this huge
piece of machine i didn't put anybody in
charge he was here
he was he's been here for 40 years 84
19 okay he's been here for many many
years uh
but and i you know you inherit a lot of
people it's part of the machinery
and you have some you love some you
don't i like them i don't agree with
them
that often but i like them and when you
look at
look back on the last four years and the
first three
were impeachment mueller
pandemic investigations
what do you say to the american people
about what they don't see
when they're doing interviews like this
how how you cope
with this constant barrage from the hill
there's always
there's always back and forth that's
fine but it's been different for you
it's been different because i've
accomplished so much on the military
i've accomplished first of all
bringing many of the troops home and
most of the troops home even cutting
down germany okay
because they've taken advantage of us
like you wouldn't believe but
it's been different for a lot of
different reasons i think primarily
because i've accomplished so much